[Applause]
okay look it's uh 1:30 but uh by a show
of hands if anybody wants to ask a few
questions they'll stay for a minute or
two or three uh but we we are looking to
to wrap this up if anybody uh would like
to go and not be part of uh the question
and answer period Please feel free to do
so for all us my question is this
there's there's one mystery at the heart
of all this which you kind of alluded to
Robert that you know there's something
bigger here
Beyond uh Beyond uh Obama's
islamism it's the fact that everybody it
seems like there's in his administration
all the people you mentioned and and the
press and so many forces in America seem
intent upon repressing free speech and
coddling everything Muslim so it's a
it's a mystery that I Ponder every day
and I wonder what your Insight is about
that what is that bigger larger
thing it's not an
accident uh this is not something that
happened
overnight uh this is a plan look there's
conspiracy theory and there's conspiracy
fact and the global Jihad is a fact and
you have to understand that the
infiltration by the Muslim Brotherhood
of government of social of cultural
forces has been going on for decades uh
as we witnessed in the Holy Land trial
the major Muslim organizations in
America nna isna Mass MSA of course our
favorite our favorite group uh care the
Council of American Islamic relations we
have a real love affair with those boys
I mean they have infiltrated at the
senior level one only had to witness
what happened to Steve cogin at the
Pentagon here is the leading uh
litigation specialist on uh the threat
Doctrine on Jihad was fired because of
the influence of uh hasham Islam on
brown right was Gordon was it Gord
Gordon England thank you Gordon Brown
the UK um uh so that's just the most
Stark example but I did a piece and if
you should you should Google it on the
Society of of professional journalists
where they have instru
on how to write about Islam how to how
to write about a terrorist attack if
don't mention religious motivation if
you have to mention religious motivation
remember to cite abortion clinic Bings
boom boom boom boom boom what I'm and
I'd like Robert to also address this as
well what I'm saying is that it's not an
accident you know you have a Molly noris
had to go into hiding here's a girl
she's What I Call The Accidental counter
jihadist because she hears about the
producers of Comedy Cent being targeted
for death by jihadists and she goes hey
let's everybody draw muhamad day you
know she's thinking like like when
America was
free and she immediately sees
immediately retracts immediately
apologizes within I think 48 Hours
doesn't matter the fact that she
apologized made her an easy target she
has had to go into hiding at her own
expense changed her name lost her job
where's how is this girl not from page
of every newspaper she's them Robin and
I we get death threats all the time I
actually ran a couple of the Wilder ones
this week because it irked it yeah were
was it irked me and it's been there for
a while it irked me that Daisy KH says
on Christian Amor's ridiculous panel a
shilling for Islam in the ground zero
mosque says well you know making fun of
Ayan has Al because Ayan has Al says to
her look
you have a great life what why do you
play the victim why you playing the
victim you have a great life great job
here you are on ABC News they're
Shilling for you she didn't say that but
and she and you got to see the real face
of Daisy Khan you got to see her in that
moment and she said you you're the
you're the victim you walk around with a
bodyguard and the mostly Muslim audience
hahaa isn't that funny it's not funny
but she say well I get death threats
too oh da Khan's getting death threats
oh my God front page New York Post New
York daily news and she's getting police
protection you ever get police
protection lawville Kurt vestard um aan
has iben War waa Sultan only American
has that has to live in hiding nobody
ever hears about oh but Daisy KH go she
got a phone call that a phone call maybe
it was just a heavy
breather I want to see proof I I'll show
you tweets about executing P Geller
snail mail email I she got a phone call
ah and and and and you can check with
the police she said yeah she called the
police I got a threatening phone call
okay yes she said she
got all right you want to address
[Music]
this uh I don't you know the larger goal
the larger strategy I I I think that
it's impossible to speculate because uh
there's just so much obviously going on
that is not being made public and uh to
to speculate on those grounds is just to
get into conspiracy theorizing and
what's the point but there is uh one
Chief engine that is running this thing
uh that certainly the Muslim Brotherhood
and the organization of the Islamic
conference are working to shape the
narrative about Islam in the west and
one of the chief ways that they're doing
that is what pamel is describing about
playing the
victim and uh it's very Insidious and
very clever and you will probably run
into it and so I think it's it's worth
noting some of these other ways in which
it works but the idea is you know in
this Society we have a history of racism
discrimination against various groups
and everybody appor that everybody hates
that and nobody wants to be put into the
position of bringing that on any other
group now and so the Council on American
Islamic relations and other Hamas linked
Muslim Brotherhood groups like them they
play that card very skillfully and say
see you're discriminating against us and
so how does that work will consider the
honor killing uh bus ad campaign no taxi
ad campaign that Pamela conceived for
stop islamization of America I don't
know if you're familiar with it but it
was a brilliant thing where pictures of
these beautiful young girls who had been
murdered by their fathers for bmer
merching the honor of the Islamic family
America in America in the United States
their photos were put up and it said
honor killing victim and and if you want
to leave Islam safely go to leave Islams
safely.com which is our site and so on
and there was all kinds of media about
it and it invariably the sto these
stories rather would invariably quote a
care spokesman or some of the Muslim
Spokes and saying uh this demonizes all
Muslims and now think about that if you
have a battered woman's shelter and this
is I'm stealing your line here but uh I
I'll pay you later um how much do these
cost uh the if you have a battered woman
shelters that demonize all husbands I
mean it's it's ridiculous it's
contrafactual it's against common sense
but they say these things all the time
and people say oh yeah we can't demonize
all Muslims therefore we can't speak
about honor
killing and so the girls keep dying yeah
it's how it
works uh yes sir I think one of the
things that we have to add to this is
our friends the saw snakes who were
bought of Georgetown
with $20 million who have bought Harbor
who have bought Princeton who have
bought every major institution in the
United States where you can't say what
you think is real and that's one of the
biggest problems we have is the soy
money
absolutely Philadelphia is is home to a
think tank I know you know at the Middle
East Forum led by Daniel P and Daniel's
no shrinking violet uh
he he has
said for years that milit Islam is the
problem in moderate Islam is solution I
haven't heard him say that recently but
what is your thought on that what's your
reaction I disagree with
[Music]
him that would be a great idea if modern
Islam existed but modern Islam does not
exist now mind you I was saying this
earlier to somebody and uh she said oh
but there are there are moderates yes
I'm not saying moderate Muslims don't
exist I'm saying moderate Islam does not
exist that's a very important
distinction that is often Allied there
are lots of Muslims who just want to
live their lives and have jobs and raise
their families and take care of
themselves and that's it they don't care
about blowing themselves up for killing
infidels and never will you know you
grow up in a culture and you bear the
name and that doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to do anything about it
there's a spectrum of belief knowledge
and fervor among Muslims just as there
is among people of any other religious
tradition or really any belief system
and in other words they're people who
know all about it and Care people who
don't know all about it and don't care
people who know all about it and don't
care Etc anyway the problem with it is
that there is no form of Islam there is
no sect there is no school of Islamic
law that does not teach that Muslim have
to wage war against unbelievers and
fight and kill them that doesn't mean
every muslim's doing it but there's no
form of Islam that doesn't teach
that so there is no moderate Islam it
would be great if it were invented and
then maybe it could be the solution but
I I don't know if we have 500 years to
work on work that
out and 10 years into pipes's plan or
where did it get us I'm just saying it's
an it's an abject failure and uh like
Robert said anecdotally we all know nice
Muslims it's got nothing to do with the
ideology that's inspiring uh these
attacks and I just don't I think it's a
waste I think it's a incredible sorry
waste of time money resources and
reality and
reality
yes first I want to thank you both for
your tremendous uh courage uh you and
few
other you and a few other courageous
people uh around the country and around
the world have done a great job of
diagnosing the problem telling us about
the problem you mentioned go vote what
other action items can we do to try and
um stamp out this problem I'm glad you
brought that up what we we've witnessed
here is a demonization of every
effective
leader this is very important because
even you I'm sure there are people in
this room that have been victim that
that have been victimized by this take
for example uh Sarah
Palin uh I think she's a great candidate
I think she's a I do I think she did
wonderful I mean they had nothing on
this woman think about it here's a
mother five children anybody in the room
who's got one kid knows what that means
goes to school does the p does the PTA
not all mothers do that okay does the
PTA gets involved she's obviously Civic
minded becomes mayor does a hell of a
job you beter you
know loves her husband husband loves her
comes uh Governor uh she's in charge of
oil she's on the oil and gas commission
goes up against the old boy Network
won't play games resigns she's her own
woman I mean she's she's
[Music]
perfect they had nothing on this woman
nothing and look what they've done look
what they've done to to this woman I
mean to say her name is to laugh what
what what what is that it's the hatred
of the good for being the good I am
proud to say that I'm affiliated with a
group called Jews for Sarah I strongly
strongly recommend that you support this
group here here we have listen back in
the day when she was uh nobody she had
an Israeli flag in her office and I do
believe that it has nothing to do with
Judaism where you stand on Israel
frankly is where your moral compasses
it's true
because in the war between the Civilized
man and the Savage you always side with
the Civilized man and that's essentially
what it's all about and she has been
stal stal on Israel we do a there are
chapters on Obama and the Jews Obama and
Israel I mean half that book is about
obam and the Jews he's clearly an
anti-semite I'm not going to go into
that now we don't have time but it's all
it's all in evidence so so yeah Alan
West John Bolton you have to oh don't
never win never you can't say that if a
guy with a resume so thin that to say
thin is actually an
exaggeration who who who background is
under such question such a question and
the media won't touch it if a man like
OB Barack Hussein Obama could become
president why can't John Bolton why
can't Sarah Palin why can't Al these are
these are righteous these are these are
America's Best
[Applause]
guys we'll have to they're going to be
at the table they're going to be signing
books I'm so sorry but we did promise be
over by now so if you'd like to stay get
a book they'll be there to answer your
questions thank you all so much
[Music]
Jen